Last week, also someone asked what to do for kaker sores.
I thought it was worth mentioning
that I have had tremendous success with my cold source
running the kaker sores cold source program on the rife.
Thank you for that reminder because I did not say that.
So here you're correcting me and appreciate that.
So I always hope everybody to go to the rife first
and here I did not do that in answering that question.
So the benefit of going to the rife first before you even go by
and I see him for your kaker sores or calcium lactate
the two things that I suggested is that you already have it
and you don't need to always add chemistry to it.
You can use frequency.
So here's a person who uses the kaker sores cold source program
and this should be for everything.
I have an infection, run the rife for infections.
I have this and run the rife for that.
That should be your first go too.
Thank you for the person who said this
because it's a good reminder for everybody
including myself.
Not only is the rife stopped the cold source from getting bad
I don't nearly get them as nearly as often
mine are stress related.
Yes, because stress remember I said cold source
are because something changes the pH of your cell
in your mouth changes and then that gives the chance
for the herpes simplex tend to come right down
the trigeminal nerve and cause of ulcer.
So stress can change the pH.
You also can eat citrus and all sorts of things.
So stress major player and out.
Last week you answered my question about leg cramps
on the keto diet.
So the person asked the question if you didn't listen
to that recording last week that they were the keto diet
and started having leg cramps really bad.
And I mentioned that I'm trying to figure through it
in my head by version of the keto diet
is heavy on the leafy greens but lacky
the variety of vegetables you said.
The fact that this diet puts me in circumstances
that creates leg cramps really makes
we doubt the overall healthiness of this diet.
I would agree that you do have to question the healthiness
of a diet when it's causing you side effects, right?
But you might be doing it for other reasons.
Maybe your glucose is like way too high.
Maybe you have diabetes and you're trying to break
that cycle of diabetes and heal yourself,
membranes and get your glucose way down.
But there's other reasons for doing it.
Maybe you have a great answer
and you're going out of ketogenic diet
and you can live with the side effects of maybe
two little minerals and you need to deal with that
maybe by taking supplements.
So there may be reasons to do it.
This person, I know what they're dealing with,
they could probably drop this diet.
So I would agree.